it has been such a treat for fans and
hikaru is like
let's go and we've got a kickoff uh yes
e4 let's go says hikaru 1 e2 e4
best by test said bobby fisher and
was he right peter well i mean we see e5
knight f3 i cannot believe magnus
hesitating here
is that right in an armageddon game you
are not supposed to be thinking you move
to
that must have been some technical issue
oh this is
this cost magnus 15 seconds
and they're repeating well they are not
entirely repeating because magnus
switched to bishop e6 set up
but yeah it was the same line this is a
much more
solid way of playing and much more
magnus style
i was about to say uh no no kidding
peter the
you look at the black king and you say
man
that that king is in great
safety with the the pawn shield of four
pawns in front of the king the knight
nearby
so no issues about the same king um
we won't drill too deeply into any
variations
just peter where i wanted to ask you
where is white's king going
aston answered peter yeah white had to
go for
long castles uh the question is
yeah uh magnus went for knight g6 and
hikaru
played knight h5 well very interesting i
mean you don't really see
this uh moves often but this exchange on
e3 playing c5 is typical stopping byte
of
from going dc d4 white has to go for f2
f4 in some
some moment now after the move b7 b6 i'm
expecting that
uh black will bring his bishop from e6
where it would did a good job a moment
ago
over to say the c6 or b7 square just a
little bit closer to the king
magnus taking his time still peter again
we are in armageddon where have you been
if you're joining us late this has been
an absolutely
epic match between two of the greatest
rapid chess players
maybe the world has ever seen knight h4
peter
yeah knight h4 this is an indication
maybe that magnus wants to shut things
down with g5
and if if that's the case then the big
question after can white play f4
f4 can be answered by g6 and then the
knight jump on g2
winning the pawn on f4 yeah incredible
uh discovery by by magdos because if he
stops any kind of f force then
white will have very little breaks
available and magnus still has
two minutes 51 on the clock it's it's
too much time
it's not so easy to play against this
clock situation
and of course uh in the armageddon
uh black has drawn odds all he needs is
a draw and he wins the
it wins the match uh but
uh white has the extra minute
and that's why you have to keep a very
very careful eye
on the clocks and i've got to tell you
peter looking at this game and magnus
has played a
perfect and i mean an absolutely perfect
oh and look at c4
oh yeah very interesting armageddon
because again you know
just he controls white's
play and hikaru desperate now
yeah and this c5 c4 was very important
because if white
would have gotten the chance of playing
king b2 then simply there was also the
chance of simply playing for the clock
situation that you
uh covered everything uh and
you can just play on but forever now the
position has this dynamics with queen c5
hitting the rook on g1 trying to force
these exchanges
the other hand hikaru played his g5 move
trying to get access to black's only
weakness on the e5 pawn
wow i love this move a7 a5
you mentioned queen c5 i also like rook
on eight
to h2 uh that's a move that white has to
keep in mind and that's
probably why we saw the move queen d3
but this move a5
basically says to the knight on c3 don't
even
hint at moving away as a5
a4 will unlock the gates to the
to your king and we've seen rook h7
we've traded rooks uh
quickly uh peter your take on the
current situation
well black has to play luke h7 exactly i
mean cover the seventh rank
because the c7 pawn is is a weakness and
the big question is what
white can do here what the hikar was
supposed to be doing and look at the
clock situation it's only
29 seconds advantage for for hikaru
knight a4 it's a it's a nice move it's
something that forces black to think
why bishop d7 get rid of that knight
okay but the bishop on e6 is so nice you
don't want to move it
and magnus after spending 15 seconds
goes back to d6 then
one feels that knight a4 was really
worth it maybe knight b2 trying to get
the knight to d3
um okay i was i wanted to
follow up with a4 uh magnus offered the
trade of queens
a a trade that was declined with queen
c3 peter
and there are issues maybe with the f3
pawn
well but also with the e5 pawn and this
queen on cc is very very nice
yeah knight b2 played white wants to go
knight dc and if he gets knight d3 and
he will get an advantage so magnus has
to go after the fc pawn
look hc played now the clock situation
is very important i mean magnus is down
to one minute 26 seconds
if something goes wrong with the with
the clock i mean the position he has to
spend more time
look d5 can it be played no knight dc
played
there was knight c5 check and queen
takes f3 oh
what is going on oh this is going to be
a
fortress a rook and bishop
versus a queen and that should be a very
easy draw for the rook and bishop
rook e1 is
no problem at all now it's about the
clock peter yeah it's all about the
clock okay
both players are phenomenally fast with
the clock
so
i mean it will be dramatic to witness
who who reflect whom
if we get we get that far right and
there we have it
it's just a rook and bishop in three
pawns
and this is just ideal uh thanks to the
pawn on
a5 uh peter yeah it's ideal but still
maybe okay i even don't know for whom
it's easier to play faster
i i believe i actually won in
dubai in the olympiad against your
countrymen lyish border shrook and
bishop versus
rook where is this b5 very important
yeah
go on yes sir yeah just i actually had
an extra
pawn so i had a rook and bishop and an
extra pawn
and i was able to win and by the way
this is bishop takes b5 as an easy draw
with the rook going back and forth
between
d6 and b6 and i also think that's true
with the pawn on b7 so now i just don't
see
any hopes at all this is very easy just
rook back and forth
yeah and look at hikaru's face yeah he
knows it that
that's it magnus has 55 seconds time is
not an issue
yeah this is going to be a draw magnus
carlsen
choosing the black pieces and that was
the difference in ikaru
laughing he knows he played a great
great great match
and he knows his opponent played just a
little bit better
wow wow wow